I don't know if you've ever noticed this
but it seems like sometimes in life the
more you want something the harder it is
to get this seems to be the case with
starting a business or writing a book or
any of these big life plans we always
dream about seems like the more we
fantasize about these types of things
the more we procrastinate doing anything
about them but there's a very specific
reason for this and it is brilliantly
explained in probably one of the best
books I have ever read in my life called
the war of art by Steven Pressfield so
in this book Steven Pressfield explains
that there is a psychological force that
is working against you every single day
of your life and is intimately involved
in every decision that you make whether
you're aware of it or not and the sole
purpose of this force is to keep you
from reaching your potential
it's called resistance now whether we've
called it resistance or not we've all
definitely felt it usually in the form
of a sort of internal tension that you
feel whenever you think about doing
something constructive whether it's
picking up a paintbrush to start
painting or opening the word doc to
start writing the essay you've been
procrastinating forever resistance will
be there to rear its ugly head because
resistance prevents progression if there
were no such thing as resistance we
would all be living according to our
highest ideals if we knew it was our
mission to write a book we would just
start writing if we knew that it was in
our best interest to do cardio so you
were faster on ice when you played
hockey we would just do cardio whenever
we thought of it we would just do cardio
there would be nothing stopping us but
unfortunately every single time we think
about doing something constructive
resistance starts to inject itself into
our being without us even realizing it
it's an automatic process and it happens
every single time so for example pretend
you're wasting time playing xbox or
something and you've been playing for a
couple of hours and the thought dawns on
you to go to the gym because it's Monday
and Monday's international chess day a
religious holiday and you really should
hit chest it's the right thing to do but
since it's the right thing to do and it
is integral for your growth as a human
being at least in that area of life
you will encounter resistance first it
usually takes the form of physical
discomfort when you think about going to
the gym while you're wasting time on
Xbox the thought of going to the gym
becomes very physically uncomfortable
you start to tense up you start to wince
at the thought of doing something more
uncomfortable than the thing you're
currently doing which is interesting
because once you're actually at the gym
it's not that bad in fact it's pretty
fun and you feel really fulfilled and
you feel like you're accomplishing
something but in that moment when you're
wasting time going to the gym seems like
a monster it seems like something you
definitely don't want to do that is
resistance and since human beings like
to stay intellectually consistent
resistance will start to creep into your
mind in the form of rationalization you
need any sort of good reason not to
encounter this physical pain of going to
the gym maybe you think about the fact
that since it's Monday and international
chess day everybody's gonna be doing
chests on Monday so there's gonna be a
huge lineup for the bench press
besides you went to the gym last week
and it takes a lot longer than one week
for you to lose all your gains and for
your muscles to deteriorate so it's
probably not a big deal if you just skip
this week you've been pretty good up
until this point and you kind of deserve
a break maybe you're familiar with this
type of pattern of thinking and it's
actually really common in its resistance
but here's something I find a little bit
more disturbing it seems like the more
important something is for your growth
as a human being the more powerful
resistance will be stopping you from
doing it a great example of this is me
and this channel when I first started
off making these videos it was just a
hobby but as you guys started watching
more and more and I've started to
develop an audience it has now become my
most viable career path sponsors are
reaching out things are happening the
audience is growing and it's great but
because of that fact resistance is
stronger than ever and for me resistance
takes the form of perfectionism whenever
I sit down to write a video I always
feel like I have to outdo the last one
it has to be the perfect video with the
perfect b-roll and it really becomes a
barrier to uploading as frequently as I
would like and as I've started to reread
the war of art by Stephen
field I've started to realize that this
type of thinking is just resistance
resistance never goes away you always
hear about famous singers and performers
and comedians who still get really
nervous before they go on stage they
encounter resistance even though they've
been doing it for decades even so what's
their response so they just not go on
stage of course not their careers would
be over but what the most successful
people do instead is they get really
good at automatically breaking past this
resistance as it presents itself and the
better you get at doing this the more
efficient you'll be at doing the right
thing instead of the comfortable thing
because when you just sit down to write
or when you just put on the running
shoes or when you just hit record
something magical happens words start to
flow endorphins start to run inspiration
starts to magically descend upon you and
all the pieces sort of fall together the
proper response to resistance is to just
start the thing anyways once you start
realizing that whatever rationalizations
you have for not doing the thing you
know you have to do is just resistance
you can gain the mental clarity to just
do the thing anyways and as you become
more familiar with resistance and seeing
it for what it is
you can really start to use resistance
as a guide since resistance is most
powerful the more important something is
it's a great compass leading you to
where you know you need to go and as you
win these battles with resistance day by
day month by month and year by year the
life you live will become bigger than
the unlived life within you and you'll
eventually start living the kind of life
you actually want to be living like I
mentioned at the beginning of the video
this entire video was based on the war
of art by Steven Pressfield the book
that I recommend the most to people is
this book and the funny thing is I
didn't actually read the book physically
I listened to it using today's video
sponsor audible I remember when I first
listened to the war of art I was looking
on Reddit for book recommendations and
the war of art came up so I downloaded
it on audible I listened to the audio
version while I was starting to clean
but something happened whenever I listen
to it for like five minutes
I had to take action on the most
important things in my life it
completely was a paradigm shifting book
the nice thing about audible is you can
listen to books while you're being
productive you can be cleaning the
kitchen you can be driving somewhere you
can be going to the gym and you can be
in taking valuable information while
you're already doing something
constructive it's like a double whammy
of productivity audible has the largest
selection of audiobooks on the entire
internet out of any platform they have
this cool deal where every single month
you can download a book of your choice
regardless of price absolutely free as
well as two audible originals so make
sure when you sign up down below for
your free trial you download the war of
art because you absolutely won't regret
it so to sign up for your 30 day free
trial either click the link below or
visit audible.com slash better ideas or
text better ideas to 500 500 if you
don't like the book you can easily
exchange it for something else at any
time and if you cancel your audible
membership you still keep your library
of books once again visit audible.com
slash better ideas or text better ideas
- 500 500 - sign up for your free 30 day
trial if you like this video make sure
to hit like because when you like it the
algorithm blesses me with shoving this
video in front of other people's faces
helping them out and I feel like this is
an important video that people kind of
need nowadays it'll knock them off their
youtube binge and set them on the right
path and if you're lurking here consider
subscribing and hitting the bell icons
so you don't miss videos like these in
the future
lots of awesome content coming up I'm
really excited for some of these future
videos make sure to stay tuned for those
thank you for watching and we'll catch
you in the next video
[Music]